بسبع الجولات اقتراح فشل مجلس النواب
الامريكي في انتخاب رئيس المجلس وسخ
خلافات بين الجمهوريين فيما يسعى
المعتدلون الجمهوريون لاقناع المجموعه
المتشدده من جناح اليمين بترشيحه كفن
مكوتي يستغلها هؤلاء نواب الغالبيه
الجمهوريه الضائله التي حققوها في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه في نوفمبر
لكي يفرضوا شروطهم ومن دون دعمهم لن يتمكن
مكارس من الوصول الى المنصب وقال نائب عن
تكساس ان الولايات المتحده تريد وجها
جديدا ورؤيه جديده وقياده جديده يشل هذا
الوضع ايضا مؤسسه مجلس النواب روماتها اذ
من دون رئيس لا يمكن للنواب ان يؤدوا
اليمين وبالتالي تمرير اي مشروع قانون ولا
يمكن للجمهوريين ايضا ان يفتحوا التحقيقات
الكثيره التي وعد بها ضد جو بعيدا وقال
النائب الجمهوري
متاسفا لدينا عمل يتعين القيام به ولا
يمكننا متابعته
المذيع شون هاريتي في الفوكس نيوز احرج
النائب اليمنيه لورين بوبرد الذي رفضت دعم
مكارتي وادخلت عمليات تصويت لرئيس مجلس
النواب وهي وهي ومجموعتها في فوضى كبيره
ولم تجب على سؤال واحد والخمس دقائق
نتابعوا جزءا من المقابله
[موسيقى]
الديمقراطيون يراقبون هذا الوضع وخلافات
الجمهوريين بشئ من المتعه حيث تكتل الحزب
الديمقراطي خلف الترشيح حكيم جفريز لكن
النائب لا يتمتع بدعم بدعم عدد كافر من
الاصوات لكي ينتخب رئيسه لمجلس النواب قد
تكون المواجهه الحاصله مؤتيه سياسيا
للجوبايدن اذا اكد نيته الترشح مره اخرى
في عام 2024 وهو قرار قد يعلنه مطلع
السلام ومن المفارقات التي شهدها اللقط
حول مجلس النواب وانا زعيم الجمهوري لمجلس
الشيوخ مش مكانه رافق الرئيس الديمقراطي
في زياره لكنتاكي للاشاده ببناء جسر
بتمويل من قانون البنيه التحتيه الذي قدمه
ونال اصوات بعض الجمهوريين في الكونغرس
المواد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]